[Music]
joanne is in west palm beach hi joanne
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and rachel thank you so much
for all you do for us people and
i am feeling so blessed that you took my
call today well we're honored how can we
help wonderful
okay so
i'm 62 years old and um i got some
problems i i am in about eighty thousand
dollars in debt
of with seventeen thousand five hundred
is car
thirty one thousand is he locked and 29
000 is credit card
i am a christian
i want to pay my bills i don't want to
make anybody
i don't want to screw anyone over i
i'm just having a hard time and
by the way i have 33 13 000 cash i've
been saving some cash because
um
there's a lot of wonkiness going on in
our world today and
i'm scared i'm i'm frightened i'm very
frightened and i lived past
the 2008 debacle
which almost made me homeless but the
lord
my lord jesus christ
sent me someone who helped me get
a loan modification
god is so good
and
that's amazing what's your household
income
my household income is wonky because i'm
in sales
last year i made 58 000 but this year i
i see that what i'm making now i'm i'm
on track to make ten thousand dollars
less and i think it's because people are
afraid to spend money
well they're spending like crazy on some
things
so how old are you
i'm i'm going i'm going to be 63 in in
june and
i know i'm never going to be able to
retire
because i don't have all but just this
13 000 in cash
so i just want to do what's best
okay
all right
well what we would tell you is that you
can retire uh you're not gonna retire
soon
but um
and if i'm in your shoes i'm gonna get
really geared up on my sales job and
instead of taking a ten thousand dollar
less i'm gonna make ten thousand dollars
more
uh because i'm gonna get geared up with
some serious goals and start plowing my
way through this debt so that i can
start investing so i have a nest egg and
if you did that for the next uh i don't
know six five six seven years i think
you not only would be
have an emergency fund but you also
could have have the beginnings of an
estate you're not going to be worth
millions of dollars but you could get
really really stable but it's going to
require a lot of hard work and diligence
on your part to do that
and so the way we teach people to do
that is called the baby steps
uh we'll send you a copy of the book the
total money makeover to show you how to
do those but rachel i think she can do
it
oh absolutely and joanne it's gonna
sound like a little bit of a mind
shift though for you because
you have a lot of credit card debt which
says something to me right i don't know
if you're spending money
just to acquire i don't know if this is
to help pay your bills i don't know what
that credit card debt is but there's a
lot there you have 17 000 car loan you
could sell the car and reduce some of
this debt by just doing that
um and looking but but the way you've
been living just by the numbers you've
given me it's a little bit all over the
place and it doesn't feel extremely
sharp and organized so
like like dave just said i'm like i
would take on an extra job
your job in sales that's right have the
mindset of like hey i'm gonna make more
this year not less i'm not gonna settle
for anything more and you go in and make
a larger income this year and then
you're going to tighten up your budget
and you're going to start working your
way out of this debt and it's going to
take a lot of intentionality
strictness um and even from your voice
you sound so kind joanne so kind
but i want you to be a little bit more
on your money and in your situation you
know what i mean a little bit of a
little bit of grit in there
to have some level of forward motion
into the baby steps um but again don't
give up i mean the age i understand can
be defeating
um because you feel like you're 62 and
you just have your 13 000 and that's it
but if you start working this process
it's going to take a little bit but you
can see progress i think you can be debt
free and have thousand two hundred
thousand dollars in the bank in seven
years
uh but you're going to make more and
you're going to be be very very diligent
list your we're going to teach you baby
step one's a thousand dollars so uh
wonkiness in the world or not i'm gonna
have a thousand dollars set aside i'm
gonna put 12 000 towards your smallest
debts listing your debts smallest
largest and that's probably those credit
cards uh they're probably individual
cards it's probably not one twenty nine
thousand dollar card so we're gonna list
those out and we're gonna use that
twelve thousand towards those smallest
ones we're going to cut them all up and
we're going to get on a budget living on
a plan and working the plan working the
plan working the steps working the plan
working the steps and again we'll show
you how to do that with the total money
makeover book and if you'll get you just
use that as this is the process this is
what we do this is the process nothing
else this is the process i've got to
work the plan i've got to work the plan
then uh you'll be able to push through
and get moving in the right direction so
hey good call thank you for joining us